last question today david do you believe
that people whose
hobby is politics actually get anything
done
politically this is a i want to be
careful in how i talk about this because
if i were to say people who just follow
politics
as a hobby and source of entertainment
don't get a damn thing done
i think it would potentially be
disaffecting to many people
my view is that and we we've done
interviews on this before and it's an
important question we've talked about it
with rachel bittikoffer and with other
people
political hobbyists don't get much done
themselves if they only remain political
hobbyists
however they may number one
by sharing information on social media
get
other people to go beyond being merely
political hobbyists and being
actual political activists who get
things done but for many people being a
political hobbyist
is the entry path into being more of an
activist someone who actually calls
elected officials organizes
uh does voter registration volunteers
for candidates etc
etc etc so if the question
you it's the devil isn't how you ask the
devil's in the details of the question
do people who never go beyond merely
following politics like entertainment
help to achieve
change very very little hopefully they
at least vote not all political
hobbyists even vote but to the extent
that they do voting is important
if the question is can being a political
hobbyist
lead to being someone that actually does
achieve
change by becoming an organizer or
someone who volunteers for campaigns or
whatever else the answer is absolutely
yes and i know tons of people and many
are in our audience
who started just by watching shows shows
like this and and other shows
and voted but then eventually really
became engaged and i can think of people
in lots of different parts of the
country where
that's the case so what is important is
not to
dismiss those who are interested in
politics
and follow it as a hobby as people who
can never get anything done
it's a matter of encouraging them to get
more involved
and there are so many ways that that can
be done either running for something at
the local level volunteering
for a local state or national election
and doing phone banking and text banking
and all these different things
people who one other thing right now
be the candidate that raises more money
in a race is more likely to win it's not
a hundred percent it's not correlated at
one
but there's a correlation between
raising more money and being able to uh
and ultimately winning
if you become a political hobbyist and
you donate money
you are also involved in a way that
materially affects outcomes
i wish that it wasn't the case that our
political system depended on money in
that way
it's a disgusting corrosive system that
must be changed
but if you're not only a political
hobbyist but someone who donates
to candidates that you believe in you
are also having an impact and we know
that and there's a reason that raising
money is so important and and such a
important factor in signaling who might
actually win an election
so let's embrace the political hobbyists
to do more
rather than writing them off as people
who make no difference and the truth is
most people
in my audience are political hobbyists
some percentage of them
are more than that and hopefully we can
encourage that number
to grow even further let me know your
thoughts we also
have a great bonus show for you today
the bonus show is only exclusively for
our
website members and patreon
donors you can sign up at joinpakman.com
you can sign up at patreon.com david
pakman show either way you'll get
instant access to the bonus show
why not do it before april is gone you
have just
hours to go i'll see you then